well and that rule was changed shortly thereafter
and now they look to see if it's a legal
goal they can review for that here comes
Lin sing Patrick Kane got some line changes going
on nice play by D bricket rocking off the far goal
post and Patrick Kane look at he's a late delay
that it went in but go to the net stick on the ice
boom just like that there he is thank you sir and
three Flyers kind of go to the puck and they don't
take point shot in off the break ofle scars kaning
gets another one well they got a really really
fortuitous bounce right here oh my goodness right
off the brink [Applause] skate very fortunate but
they were way overdue to have something like
this happen off the skate right to cat cider
gosis Bear DE Brink it looks like a power play but
it's not here's Kane with a shot just one rebound
they [Applause] score you see 41 down low I'd have
to read this again to see if Kane purposely shot
wide or not I I don't think he did but boy oh boy
what a again the P Che pressure by Detroit they
had the Philadelphia Flyers hemmed in and Patrick
Kane can end it first shootout attempt as a
Redwing two and one in the game Patrick Kane scars
bred Wings win it 7-6 Patrick Kane what a night
[Music] [Applause] wow boy that's the surgical
hands I talked about tonight out of number 88
holy moly woo gee and the hats Kenny they're
throwing hats on the ice it's an unofficial
Patrick not a hatrick cuz shootouts don't count in
your stats but we'll give Kane
the Patrick merry Christmas
everybody an excited red WI bench I guess so
after losing a 5-1 lead they get an important
two points and hopefully this BS well for
tomorrow night in New Jersey glad you're
with us tonight John keing Red Wings Live a
merry merry night for the Red Wings and the
red wi faithful in attendance what a Christmas
party this turned out to be and alls well that
ends well the Wings win it by a 76 final
Jimmy Howard's alongside post game reaction
from the Red Wings dressing room including
from Patrick Kane and from New Zeal alone
when Red Wings Live begins in just a moment on a
breathless Friday night in downtown hockey town